mais ça y est la glace est cassée oui ça
se passe bien très bien marché
Jean-Talon on est bien prête pour un
bein alors premier test de goût Myriam
mais pour vous aussi un de vos segments
préférés et ça fait deux ans et demi
qu'on en a pas fait depuis le début de
la pandémie alors aujourd'hui on a
décidé de se gâter oui on a choisi un
aliment qui est lié au plaisir à la
nostalgie et qui plaît autant aux
amateurs de sucré que de Salé maïs
soufflé sucré on goûte quatre produits
identifiés par le point bleu le
compliment par le point jaune les
crackers Jack le rouge impérial et le
blanc le waters original place à la
dégustation
avec du beurre comme assaisonnement mais
il y a aussi ce qui est très populaire
et de plus en plus le même soufflé
enrobie de caramel à quelle occasion au
cinéma nos collation film à la maison
mais ça serait fun que cela soit dans
les salles de cinéma
[Rires]
quand on regarde l'ensemble des produits
il y a quand même un petit peu de fibres
parfois il y a même un peu de protéines
alors c'est sûr que c'est pas un bonbon
mais on pourrait dire que c'est une
friandise effectivement dans la majorité
des cas
[Musique]
un peu
doux un peu beurré un peu dans ce
produit là on a aussi du beurre qui est
utilisé donc c'est pas le cas de tous
les produits donc c'est sûr que ça
risque de donner une saveur plus
distinctive mais aussi un peu plus de
matière grasse saturées qui sont les
gras qui sont généralement moins
associés à une meilleure santé la
pension déférence qui est inscrite sur
les étiquettes c'est 50 g donc c'est à
peu près une tasse une tasse et demi
ce qui est intéressant de constater
c'est la présence de sucre donc c'est
vraiment il y a plus de sucre en termes
de poids dans le produit que de maïs
donc c'est le premier ingrédient sur la
liste et l'industrie alimentaire va
souvent combiner plusieurs types de
sucre on retrouve du sucre de la
cassonade parfois on ajoute à ça aussi
du sirop de riz brun pour faire varier
la couleur des produits la texture donc
les produits ne se ressemblent pas même
s'ils sont tous à savoir de caramel
c'est bon c'est bon
pour moi c'est
trop sucré
c'est vraiment bon mais ils sont tous
bons mais voilà
vous avez choisi plus cher
[Rires]
du vrai beurre aussi à l'intérieur très
bon tu te sens bien qu'à la maison
dans celui-là aussi on utilise du beurre
donc il y a quand même une quantité un
petit peu plus élevée de grosses
saturées plus de sodium et également
c'est un de ceux qui sont les plus
sucrés
[Musique]
c'est un goût un peu
ouais le cornichon
dehors mais à l'intérieur c'est une
carrière
c'est comme s'il y avait une couche de
friandise de siropracteur à l'extérieur
et vraiment on goûte la mélasse liste
d'ingrédients assez épurés
utilisation d'huile végétale donc ce
produit là beaucoup beaucoup plus de
gras insaturés et ce qui est intéressant
aussi dans le produit c'est la teneur en
sodium et comme il y a des arachides on
remarque un peu plus de protéines un peu
plus de film que tout les autres
produits qu'on a dans notre panel et
donc ça en fait un produit un petit peu
plus intéressant je dirais d'un point de
vue nutritionnel
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé quand même pas trop sucré
j'ai super sucré c'est pour ça que je
préfère
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'un petit
peu moins de sodium et également moins
de grosses saturés en les voies
utilisées de l'huile de canola de
l'huile de tournesol alors c'est ce qui
fait en sorte que le produit contient
moins de grosses saturées et plus de
gras insaturés
on a vraiment le goût de maïs et le goût
du caramel en même temps est-ce que ça
vous donnerait envie de d'en acheter
plus régulièrement maintenant vous avez
goûté
[Musique]
si on consomme le sac c'est sûr que on
vient faire x 5 à toutes les valeurs
nutritives évidemment que c'est pas
quelque chose que je recommanderais de
consommer là pour déjeuner disons et
soutenir sa fin ça reste un aliment un
aliment plaisir je dirais
était le préféré des amateurs de maïs
soufflés sucré mais maintenant il est
des classes peut-être que la surprise
ait pu assez attrayante c'est le goût du
beurre qui a été préféré par nos
goutteurs notamment le worthers original
qui a été le favori merci à tous
[Musique]